HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE
HEARING TO ORDER AND SECRETARY
CAN CALL THE ROLL. IT IS DAMAGE
TO QUORUM. THE CALDERON. DAVIES
HERE ARAMBULA. BRIAN CHOI HERE
STONE. PHILIP HERE WARD. YOUR
THANK YOU. WELCOME TO THE
SEPTEMBER TENTH CARRYING OF THE
ASSEMBLY HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE TO STARTED LIKE TO
THANK ALL THE STAFF TO BE
POSSIBLE OUR ABILITY TO
MAXIMIZE OPPORTUNITIES FOR SAY
PARTICIPATION IN OUR HEARINGS
TO THAT END UNLESS YOU'RE A FEW
NOTES ABOUT THE LOGISTICS OF
OUR HEARING TODAY REGARDING THE
PUBLIC'S ACCESS TO THE
DISCUSSIONS. TODAY EN ROUTE
FORTY TWO OH TWO WERE HAVING TO
PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN PERSON
HEARING IF ANYONE. IN THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY ON THE BILL. PLEASE
RAISE YOUR HAND IF THE
APPROPRIATE TIME AND I'LL ASK
YOU TO APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
THESE ARE NOT TIED TO
MICROPHONE WILL BE IS IN A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN.
TESTIFY ON THE BILL. THE CALL
IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE.
FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO. YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON
YOUR TV SCREEN. ONE MOMENT.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA TAKE A BRIEF
PAUSE FOR WAITING FOR LDC.
OKAY
THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. FIVE SEVEN AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE DO SO NOW
OPERATE IN A LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN QUEUE BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THE SPELL. WHEN CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALBRECHT
BACKGROUND NOISE THIS INCLUDES
MUTING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCASTING YOUR SMART DEVICES
TO REDUCE. THE SAN DISTORTION.
I'D LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THE ASSEMBLY HAS ENCOUNTERED
REPEATED DISRUPTIONS OF ITS
PROCEEDINGS IN RECENT YEARS
THESE DISRUPTIONS HAVE
INCREASED THIS YEAR. RECENT
pPROCEEDINGS HERE IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND AT THE U. S.
CAPITOL NECESSITATE CONSISTENT
ENFORCEMENT OF LAWS AND RULES
AGAINST DISRUPTION. CONDUCT
THAT DISRUPT DISTURBS OR
OTHERWISE IMPEDES THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF THIS HEARING IS
PROHIBITED. IF DISRUPTIVE
BEHAVIOR OCCURS TODAY YOU'LL BE
REMOVED FROM THE HEARING ROOM
BY THE ASSEMBLY SERGEANTS OR
YOU WILL BE REMOVED FROM THE
CALL. K. TODAY WE HAVE ONE
MEASURE ON FILE AB SIX SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO GO AHEAD WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB THREE SIX
SIX ADDRESSES SHORTCOMINGS
REGARDING SIBLING PLACEMENT
WITHIN OUR FOSTER YOUTH SYSTEM
WE ARE ALL AWARE OF THE VARYING
COMPLEXITIES FOUR SIBLINGS
WITHIN THE FOSTER SYSTEM AND
THE VALUE OF PRIORITIZING
SIBLINGS BEING PLACED TOGETHER
IN WELL IS WELL ESTABLISHED. IN
PRACTICE HOWEVER TOO MANY
CHILDREN REMAIN SEPARATED FROM
THEIR SIBLINGS AND RELATIVES
DUE TO BARACK BUREAUCRATIC
HURDLES THAT ARE NOT RELATED TO
CHILD SAFETY THIS OFF OFTEN
HAPPENS DUE TO CAPACITY
RESTRICTIONS IN EXISTING LAW
WHICH THIS BILL WE'RE REMEDY
WHILE STILL RETAINING
PROTECTIONS FOR TO CHAT BEFORE
FOR THE CHILD AND HOME SAFETY.
AB THREE SIXTY THREE SIXTY SIX
STRENGTHENING EXISTING
PROTECTED PROTECTIONS IN THE
FOSTER SYSTEM ASSURING SIBLINGS
ARE PLACED TOGETHER ON THIS
THERE IS A SHOWING THAT
PLACEMENT WOULD BE CONTRARY TO
THE WELL BEING AND SAFETY OF
ANY SIBLING THE LEGISLATURE HAS
LONG PRIORITIZE THE KERR OF
YOUTH IN OUR FOSTER SYSTEM IN
THIS MEASURE WILL REFLECT THIS.
THIS BILL HAS ENJOYED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAS BEEN
CAREFULLY CRAFTED WITH THE
INPUT OF THE DEPARTMENT THANK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SOME A
MEMBER RUBIO. OKAY WE I
UNDERSTAND WE DON'T HAVE ANY
WITNESSES- SECRETARY THAT'S
CORRECT OKAY. TO EAT. I DON'T
SEE ANY PUBLIC SUPPORT IN THE
ROOM. OPERATOR TO HAVE ANY
PUBLIC SUPPORT ON THE LINE. IT
IS INTERNET TO SHOW SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE TO ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO LINES FOR
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
OPERATOR- DO WE HAVE ANY PUBLIC
OPPOSITION. TO THIS BILL.
WITNESSES NO I DON'T SEE ANY
PUBLIC OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM
OPERATORS ARE ANYBODY IN KEY ON
THE LINE. FOR OPPOSITION. SHOP
ADDITION FOR THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN THERE WITH THIS
TIME. WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU OPERATOR DO
WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE
AUTHOR FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
NO OKAY. WE DO HAVE A MOTION.
AND A SECOND- SECRETARY PLEASE
COPE AND- DO YOU WANT TO CLOSE
DOWN THANK YOU JUST RESET
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS CONCUR
CALDERON AYE WALDRON AYE DAVIES
DAVIES I ARAMBULA BRIAN. BRIAN
ALL RIGHT CHOI HI CHOI AYE
STONE STONE AYE FILOPODIA. I
WARD LORD HI. THANK YOU THANK
YOU AND I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR ALL THEIR
WORK AND APPRECIATE THAT YOU
PUT THIS TOGETHER SO QUICKLY
YOU'RE WELCOME OKAY THIS
HEARING IS ADJOURNED.